Okay. Hello everyone. It's Michael
Valtos here and this is the second video
on the indicators that I'm doing. This
one is on the Voltos flip orderflow
indicator. And again, I'm creating this
video to, you know, sort of go more in
depth and give you more in-depth
knowledge of how to use the indicator
and, you know, how to get the maximum
benefit out of it. you know, cuz like I
said, you know, people were getting this
indicator and just using it, you know,
as the basic default settings and and
not even trying to explore how to use it
and then saying, you know, it's it's not
working. But it's actually a very
effective indicator if you take the time
to understand, you know, that each
market is different. You know, you can't
use the same settings that you would on
a E- mini chart that you would use on a
Eurocurrency chart or a bond chart
against a crude chart. you know, each
market has different volume and you
know, different participants. So, it
trades in general the same but slightly
different. You know, volumes are
different. When you're trying to analyze
volume, you can't use the same volume
settings for a very liquid market as you
would for a thinner traded market. But
before I jump in, um, a brief
disclaimer. This presentation is for
educational andformational purposes only
and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision. Future trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor. An investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment. Risk capital is
money that could be lost without trading
uh sorry without jeopardizing one's
financial security or lifestyle. Only
risk capital should be used for trading
and only those with sufficient risk
capital should consider trading. Past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results. The CFTC
rules uh 4.41 hypothetical or simulated
performance results have certain
limitations. Unlike actual performance
record simulator results do not actual
represent actual trading. Also since the
trades have not been executed the
results may have under or
overcompensated for the impact of any of
certain market factors such as lack of
liquidity. Simulated trading programs in
general are also subject to the fact
that they are designed with the benefit
of hindsight. No representation is being
made that any account will or is likely
to achieve profit or losses similar to
those shown. And you know you know at
the end of this you know the later part
of this presentation I'm going to take
you through the month of January for you
know many contracts so you can see how
effective this indicator really is. You
know, I said it bothers me that,
you know, some traders just want
everything, you know, red light, green
light, without one, understanding why
there's a red light or green light, and
two, without understanding that, you
know, each market is different, right? I
mean, you can't use the same settings. I
mean, really, I mean, people were
getting this indicator. There's a
default setting. You know, it's it's a
it's an indicator, so you have to have a
basic setting, and they're just using
the setting that was there. I mean, I
don't know if they didn't read the
instructions or or what, you know, maybe
they're very eager, but you know, I I
include a a short trading guide that
goes with it, and it explains, you know,
some of the
reasons why you have to change the
settings, but you know, people would try
and literally an hour later saying, "Oh,
this is the worst thing ever. You know,
how could you put that out?" Well, then,
you know, I jump into, you know, why is
what what chart you're looking at?
What's your settings? then it's, you
know, it's basically,
you know, they're not using good, you
know, effective settings for, you know,
for whatever market or whatever time
frame they're they're trading. Um, you
know, I'm trying to put it think of how
to put it in real life terms, but again,
you know, the basic thing is each market
trades
differently in the sense of volume,
right? Like I said, you can't if you're
using an indicator that measures um
traded volume,
you can't use the same settings as you
would for a very highly liquid market
like the E- Minis that you would for a
thinner traded market as the mini DAO. I
mean, you just you just can't, you know,
it'll really give you bad readings um
you know, for one market and give you
too many readings for the other market.
So anyway, um you know, let's let's I
put this short presentation together.
It's not short. It's probably about an
hour, but um you know, I just want to go
over the background of how the indicator
started, why I came up with the
indicator, and what it does. And you
know, sort of get down to the basics.
Why do many traders fail?
Well, they fail because they break the
most important rule of trading. Keep
your losses small and let your winners
run. What that means is to take small
losses and take the big winners. But
what ultimately happens is traders take
the small winners
and, you know, take big losing trades.
You know, that's the opposite of what
they're supposed to be doing, you know.
So,
how to do it correctly? Well, you have
to know when you're wrong. You know, if
if you can't tell when you're wrong in
the market, then you're not going to
have small losses. You know, it's it's I
hate to say it's fine to have small
losses. I mean, again, you know, nobody
wants to have losses, but, you know,
that's part of trading. Sometimes you're
just wrong. Sometimes,
you know, you you get a reading and it's
it's wrong. You know, sometimes there's
somebody on the other side of, you know,
I say the other side of you, but you
know, someone else sitting in another
office somewhere that's got to do the
opposite of what you just did. Um, you
know, you can't predict that. There's a
certain unpredictability
in the market.
And you know, the flip indicator, this
indicator was designed to pick up
immediate changes in market direction
based on a big buyer or seller
dominating the bar that you're in. And
by dominating, what do I mean? I mean in
near total control. And you know there
are instances where in a bar
nearly all the volume 95% even in some
cases you know 99.8% 8% of the volume is
traded on one side, you know, either the
offer side, meaning a big buyer with
very little aggressive selling activity,
meaning, you know, all the buying is
aggressive buying and there's nothing
being traded on the other side. You
know, on the bid side, there's no
sellers. And when that happens,
sometimes it's very fast. You know, the
bar closes extremely fast. And the same
is true for the other side. um you know
when 95% or more of the volume traded
on the bid side that means you have
aggressive sellers. You have somebody
coming into the market just hitting
every bid. Okay? And again it's hard to
tell that. I mean well it's not hard to
tell. You can't see it on a normal bar
chart. A normal bar chart is just going
to give you you know the open high, low
and close. And if you're looking at an
orderflow chart, yeah, you can pick it
up by looking at the volume footprint.
But you know, not everybody understands
what they're looking at on a volume
footprint. That's one of the reasons why
I created these indicators. You know,
it's some of these things, you know,
people
take my concepts and, you know, try to
repackage them, call them, I'll go this,
I'll go that, when it's just, you know,
a tool to help you read the order flow.
Again, you know, this not a holy grail
trading system. If you think it is, you
know, you just, you know, flip off this
video right now because, you know, it's
not. you know, at the end of the day,
trading comes down to making the
decisions yourself. Um, you know,
everyone, you know, the big move
nowadays, you know, I just reading the
the paper this morning and and last
couple days, you know, there's some guys
out in Silicon Valley, you know, they're
trying to create the AI hedge fund, you
know, artificial intelligence,
you know, like like it's some new thing,
you know, but artificial intelligence,
you know, has been around in in the
trading. I I remember I bought a
software on artificial intelligence back
in the '9s. I never got it to, you know,
work meaningfully for me, but you know,
it's not like some new thing that's
coming. You know, everyone talks about,
you know, I got all these self-driving
cars, you know, and it's great. It's
um you know, I like the fact that, you
know, some of these cars can self- park
in a tight parking space. Yeah, that's
that's nice. I do stress though
sometimes watching how they they try and
park. But um you know and I always take
when I read those articles about these
self-driving cars, you know, having very
little accidents. Well, it's not the
accident that they're in. I I wonder
they should do a study on how many
accidents are caused by self-driving
cars. Meaning the self-driving car
itself didn't get into the accident, but
you know, the the cars behind it are the
ones that crashed. You know, you see
them on the movies. You know, the the
girl's driving, she just got her
driver's license. She thinks she's a
great driver and she's swerving in and
out. She's not getting into the
accident, but all the cars behind her
are piling up and uh, you know,
everybody is is cursing and and
swearing. So,
it's, you know, it's it's one of those
things where it's, you know, is is it
the new thing in the market? No. I mean,
it's a new buzz word. you know AI I'll
say it's not even new but you know
people try and come up with you know new
ways to analyze the market but at the
end of the day it's traders that are
making the decisions and
you know this indicator is based on my
own trading experience you know because
I've sat in a bank I've sat at you know
a large commodity trading firm where
you're moving size you know and
sometimes you got to move an enormous
amount of size and in a very short time
and you know But what you're going to be
doing sometimes is going to be sweeping
the market. You know, people talk about
flipping. Oh, you know, you you sell
a,000 to buy 10,000. You know, you try
and push it down. You know, the reality
of that is it sounds good in theory.
There's only a few people out there that
really do it cuz you know, one, it takes
you got to be very highly capitalized
and two, it sort of borders on um
I say illegal activity. I mean, spoofing
is illegal activity. flipping I don't
think yet really makes that threshold
because you know you are trading and in
the market spoofing is just showing your
intent but flipping you know you are
trading one direction then you turn
around and flipping the exchanges don't
like it when you buy and sell to
yourself um but sweeping you know is
more
more indicative indication of a market
that's moving very fast and you know
what sweeping is is you know a trader
comes in and say hey I need to buy 5,000
e- minis what's in the book and they
just buy everything or you know the next
three or four price levels if they can
get everything done they're just
sweeping everything in the order book
and it's very important because it
signals that there's either quick
accumulation or quick distribution. you
know, sometimes, you know, these big
hedge funds that, you know, you know,
trading in notional amounts, you know,
um, $100 million, $200 million, you
know, they'll say, okay, they'll tell
the their trader, you know, they'll get
the the the, uh, PM, the portfolio
manager will say, hey, you know what, I
want to buy, you know, 200 million bucks
worth of E- minis,
and he'll give it to the trader, and the
trader will just, you know, execute it
as as best he can. And sometimes that
means just sweeping the market, getting
it done, and you know, because they want
to get it done really quick. And this is
what this indicator does. You know, it
picks up on that. Is it 100% accurate?
No. Um, nothing is when it comes to
trading. You know, I I wish that I could
devise a a method that would give me
100% winners, but you know, there's
nothing
in this world that's 100% um you know,
ever. So, you know, get that out of your
mind that, you know, you have you can
have something that's high percentage,
but
it's not going to be 100%. You know, at
the end of the day, the market's made up
of human emotions and perceptions of
value. Everyone talks about how
computers and algos are affecting the
market, but you know what? At the end of
the day,
at the end of the day, it's individual
traders that are doing the, you know,
making the ultimate decisions to buy and
sell at the big macro hedge funds, you
know, at the big commodity trading
firms. And it's based off of supply and
demand that drives the market. Now, you
know, computer algos may be good at
picking up um you know, the these little
crumbs of, oh, you know, this one's
mispriced by a tick or two, you know,
and come in and swoop it up. Okay, that
that's all well and good, but you know,
those aren't where trends develop from.
You know, that's just uh you know,
picking up the little ARB opportunities.
And you know what you want to be getting
going back to, you know, the first slide
is, you know, having small losses and
letting your winners run is you want to
be getting in when trends are starting,
right? Not when, you know, there's a
little ARB opportunity in the market
because, you know, you're not concerned
with those little ARB opportunities. You
want to be getting in when there's a
trend about to start or a trend is
ending. You know, at the end of the day,
you know, it's markets move based on,
you know, traders
perceptions of the market now versus
where it's going to be in the future.
And people tend to get lost in that
actually. you know, they they tend to
forget it and,
you know, just try and, you know, let
the market uh sorry, let the trading
system, you know, via whatever method
they're using try and pick it up rather
than understand why the market's moving
more than anything else. You know, if
you understand why the market's moving,
why the market's reacting at a certain
price, then,
you know, it'll put you so far ahead of
the rest of the traders out there that
are, you know, using mathematical
formulas over the last 50 bars and
trying to determine that, well, you
know, where we are now is far from where
we were 40 bars ago. You know, I mean,
that's a bit of a stretch. I mean, you
know, if if you're trading lower than
where you were 40 bars ago, that that's
good. That's good to know. But, you
know, wouldn't you rather know about 35
bars ago, you know, that the market's
heading lower? And that's the difference
of what uh order flow gives you. It
basically gives you that advantage of
knowing what's happening
right now, you know, and take advantage
of it. So,
what's so good about the flip, you Well,
it signals an area where there's strong
buyers or sellers. By strong I mean
total control you know and that often
occurs before a big move you know when
like I said you know understanding how
trends start you know trends start
because of long-term traders coming into
the market they have a view and they
start accumulating a position or if it's
at a high they start distributing a
position you know maybe they have a
position on and they start dumping it or
you know what they think it's very
overpriced and they start selling it. So
you know there's a lot of reasons why it
can occur. It could be an important
level, could be a new position being
established, be taking profits. There's
a lot of reasons and I'm not going to
get into them right now, but you know,
because I don't think it's that
important, but what's important is being
able to pick it up and understand that
there's a shift in the market.
Now,
there'll be times with this indicator
that you get a signal
in direction, then immediately an
opposite signal.
And like like what I mean immediately
like either the next bar or the bar
after. Don't be discouraged by that
because sometimes you know market moves
in one direction really quick and snaps
back immediately as the algos notice
that it's uh out of whack and kick in.
Like I said you know these there's these
alos just sitting there you know waiting
for the market be what they think
mispriced by a tick or two and you know
just come in and put it back in line.
You know that's what these algos really
do. Um, and you know, honestly, if you
think you're going to compete with alos,
you're not competing with alos cuz
they're
thousand times faster than than the
human. And then they know what to do.
Where whereas if you're trading by
yourself, you know, sitting there
clicking point and click, you're not
going to you're not going to beat them.
They're sitting on on these servers, you
know, just right next to the CME server.
And you can't it's impossible. You know,
just back in be before people realized
that
and I say before it became really known,
there were these prop trading firms,
they realized that being in the same
building, the board of trade building
where the board of trade servers were
put them at an advantage. Um, you know,
this was before all this electronic
trading really um, you know, took off
with people,
you know, basically programming black
boxes. you know, the these were traders
that were just point and clicking. They
realized they were faster being in the
board of trade building where the
servers were than than someone, you
know, two blocks away in another
building. So,
you know, now it's it's at the point
where, you know, you could rent server
space. The exchange knows that it's it's
an advantage and they charge up the
wazoo for, you know, being able to place
your server there. I mean, for you, you
can get a server with uh, you know, a a
server hosting company,
not at a really at a relatively
inexpensive. By relatively inexpensive,
I mean like a 100 bucks a month. That's
quick, but I mean, if you're a hedge
fund and you want to do it, you know,
your own server, you know, it's going to
cost you a lot of money. But
anyway, so there's going to be times
where you get a a signal in one
direction, then immediately you get
another one. Like here, this is a buy,
then comes back with a sell. You know,
here's a buy and comes back with a sell
real quick and then another buy real
quick. Sometimes it happens, you know,
when a market is in a range and
sometimes it happens like this. You
know, the market sold off really quick,
you get a buy signal, but then you know
what, the sellers come back in and say,
"Hey, you know what? This is, you know,
we're going lower." And whack it lower.
I mean, don't be discouraged by that.
You know, it's about taking small lo
like, you know, going back to the first
slide, take small losses and let your
winners run. You know, if here you could
take a small loss, one, two, three small
losses, even here, four. Okay, but then
you get the nice move down here. That's
what you want, right? It's being able to
recognize you're wrong. How do you
recognize you're wrong? Well, you know,
if you violate, you know, where your
entry is, right? If if you come down
against if it comes down against you
really quick, really fast. I mean, you
could
maybe later I I'll talk about, you know,
where you should be placing your stops
to get out. Um, but yeah, I will when I
go through the examples.
So again, you know, if you're trading US
products, trade during the US trading
hours, 7:00 a.m. to 3:00 p.m. when
there's the most volume
and, you know, outside those times, you
know, less volume and the underlying
cash markets are closed. So the moves
are based on what other markets are
doing. So, you know, if you're trading
E- Minis at, you know, midnight, you're
you're trading based off of what's
happening in Japan, and you don't know
what's going on in Japan if you're
sitting in your trading room in your
house at midnight. Um, and again, you
know, not every market trades the same
way. You know, the flip indicator deals
with delta,
which is, you know, the difference
between the volume traded on the bid,
the volume traded on the offer. And each
market has its own way of trading. you
know, the 5 years ZF
just slopes along. It's a slow moving
contract. You know, some traders are
happy to get five or six ticks because
they can trade size in that market very
easily. You know, I know some guys that
just try and get one or two ticks that
are very happy because they trade a,000,
not a,000, 100 lots and, you know, 100
lots and they're done for the day. Okay.
Euro currency can be more volatile and
you get moves 20 ticks and up. And the
biggest problems traders make is they
treat each market the same. Again, you
know, don't use the default settings of
the indicator. I'm going to go through
settings that you can use because if you
use the default settings,
it's such a general setting. On some
markets, it will, but the majority of
the markets, it won't work effectively.
And you have to approach each market
differently because, you know, if you're
trading a three- range S&P chart, it's
going to have a general setting that's
going to be different than say a
10-minute NQ chart. Okay? Or a one
minute E- mini chart. You're going to
look at differently than you would a one
minute mini Dow chart.
Unfortunately,
many traders
have been doing with these indicators is
being and being let down. And when I say
that, I mean, I'm talking about using
the default settings. You know, they
they think it's a done for you setting.
It's not, okay? It's it's a default
setting because you have to have a
default setting in there. And you know,
if you're just loading the indicator on
your chart with the default setting,
it's probably not going to look very
nice. Okay, I wish I could go in and,
you know, maybe in a future edition, you
know, we'll go in and and change
different settings, but it's like uh I
don't even know how to put it in real
life terms, but you know, keep in mind
when when you're dealing with delta and
volume and order flow, you have to take
into context the market you're trading.
It's not a one-sizefititall indicator in
the sense that the settings you use for
one market will be the same for every
other market. No, it won't. Keep the
market in context. Now, you know, keep
the market in context is also leads into
this next thing I want to talk about is
times to trade. I can't stress this
enough.
People, I don't know if they don't
listen or just don't care, you know,
damn the torpedoes. I'm going to trade
no matter what whenever I get a signal.
Okay. Well, you got to be careful. You
know, don't I'm not a big fan of trading
around data releases or announcements.
For example, an unemployment number
first Friday of every month or a Fed
announcement. You know, what happens
when you have these times is volume
dries up and you get quick moves back
and forth in one direction literally in
seconds. And sometimes it's in the same
second you get 10 bars and you get a big
move within 2 seconds and the result is
you get chopped up or you get your head
cut off if you're on the wrong side of
the market. You know if it just moves in
one direction very fast. I mean why take
that chance? Okay. It's like
you know you think well it's cold
outside. I could walk across this frozen
lake. But you don't know how thick the
ice is. Well you know it's cold. You you
see there's a layer of ice. You want to
take the risk? No. you know, you got to
wait till it gets colder and the lake
freezes more. And it's like the same
with trading. You wait for the market to
settle down.
For example, here you have, you know,
this is the Euro currency. This is on
last month's, you know, January's
non-farm payrolls. 7:30. You know, this
time here
from this bar all the way to,
you know, this bar. This is 7:30. This
is the one minute. And you can see this
is a eight range chart and it's moving
all over the place. You get sell, buy,
buy, sell, buy, sell. I mean, yeah, even
though you get some smallers, you can't
react fast enough. By the time you think
you get this buy here, you buy it, it's
already trading down here and then you
should probably be short. But, you know,
just sit it out. I mean, you know,
there's nobody's holding a gun to your
head saying, "Hey, you have to trade at
this time when the number comes out."
No, you know, the the
I learned very early on in my career
when I was on the trading floor and you
know, we you'd have this Fed announce.
This was back in the '90s when the Fed
started raising rates
and, you know, it was quite regularly
actually. And you would just look, you
know, at the dealers, you know, around
the the trading pit, you know, when, you
know, the Fed makes an announcement,
who's active. It was all the retail
traders out there, you know, people that
know what's going on and, you know,
thinking how this is going to affect
their portfolio, you know, everyone's
going in every direction. It's the
professional traders, you know, the ARB
guys,
you know, even the ones, you know, the
institutional phone banks, you know, at
these at these companies, you know, cuz,
you know, each brokerage company, they
would have a retail desk and an
institutional desk, you know, the
institutional desk would just be quiet.
You know, their big customers were just,
you know, sitting it out and and waiting
and watching, you know, waiting for the
market to settle down.
before jumping back in. And you know, so
that's one of the reasons why you get
these big movements is because there's
the liquidity just isn't there. The big
players aren't there. And you know even
these hedge funds when the numbers come
out when these big numbers come out or
announcements you know they have
instructions with their the trading desk
you know pull my stop out of the market
and you know if it gets there call me
but don't just start executing it you
know because if the market spikes up on
very thin volume they don't want to be
stopped out of the market you know they
want to reassess it you know that's what
they're paid millions of dollars to do
is assess the market not just you know
take things blindly
say you wait for the market to settle
down. Don't necessarily just jump in
because, you know, oh, it's, you got a
lot of signals here and it's, you know,
this one worked, this one didn't work,
that one didn't work. Oh, you know, this
is the worst thing ever. You know, take
it in context of the market. If the
market is got a period of no volume
because, you know, the the non-farm
payroll number came out, you know, which
is the biggest number for the market
each month.
You know, why why are you trading at
that time? I mean, you shouldn't be. If
anything, you just be sort of sitting
back, you know, sipping in a glass of
water waiting for the market to settle
down. And, you know, it does. You know,
this is later 7:40.
Okay? I'm not saying, you know, 740.
Usually, me personally, I give it about
15 minutes, but this is 7:42ish, 7:42.
You know, you get a nice trend now, the
trends are going to start to develop.
You know, then, okay, later 9:00, you
get a nice little move here, comes back
up. You know, people say, "Well, it came
back up. I got stopped out up here." You
know, it was in your favor all this
time. you should have done something
taken some money off the table.
Nevertheless, you know, again, a little
bit later, 9:30, you get another buy.
You know, the market uh makes a nice
move,
nice move higher.
Okay, so settings. All right, most
important thing, do not use the default
settings thinking that's all you need.
No, especially if you don't understand
when going into the settings. If you're
using the default settings without
understanding what you're looking at,
then you know, you're just going to be
lost. I mean, it's like having a map but
not knowing how to read a map. Um, my
wife doesn't know how to read a map for
some reason. I don't know why. And she
say, "Oh, I never learned in school."
Well,
you know, don't you want to learn? You
know, she she'll complain when I'm
driving and I get lost and I ask her to
look at a map. You know, it's my fault
that we're lost, but okay. You know,
let's look at a map and try to figure
out where we are. I don't know how to
read a map. Well, if you don't know how
to read a map, then you'll never get to
where you're going, right? And if you
don't understand the settings and you're
just going to use whatever default
settings, you know, it'll be like I got
GPS in my car, but lots of times the GPS
is wrong because, you know, it hasn't
been updated in a couple years, I think.
You know, now some roads are closed and
and whatnot. But if you're using, you
know, the default settings, you know,
you're going to run into those, you
know, those closed roads on the GPS. So
you know I'm giving you these settings
you know in less liquid markets you know
like eurourrencurrency mini Dow NASDAQ
mini NASDAQ
minute charts or range charts you know
you go with one and 25 I'm going to
explain what the one and 25 mean in the
more liquid markets you know go with one
and 250 you know ES 5 years somebody
asked me what this was 5 years I should
change that I'm going to put it to ZF ZF
is the electronic symbol for 5 years FV
is the old uh
the old floor code for 5 years. You
know, when when these markets went
electronic, they had to differentiate
the electronic contracts for the quote
systems from the floor. And so all the
electronic contracts ended up with a Z
in front at the board of trade. Mini DA
YM was just strictly electronic, I
believe. But like ZB for bonds, um ZC
for corn, you know, on the floor corn
was just C, you know, soybeans, ZS. um
that's how they differentiated them you
know now everything is electronic so
they just keep the symbols um but when
the markets were side by side trading
side by side then you know cuz there's
people sitting you know outside the pit
watching the quotes on the screen and
versus what's happening in the pit so
they needed to just have the quote feed
for the electronics and that's how it
was differentiated so again you know
that shows my age a little bit but um if
you're if you if you see me say like FV
that's the old floor symbol or uh legacy
is the term the old legacy term for uh 5
years. That's why if you look at some of
these books from written before the '9s
on trading you you'll sometimes you'll
see these codes that you know FV or TY
or US for bonds. Um but anyway that's
where it came from. But again um don't
use the default settings on the
indicator thinking that's all you need.
Now settings when I say one and 25, what
I mean is this area here. There's flip
A, there's flip B. I treat them the
same.
And
why there's flip A, why there's flip B
is because there's,
you know, sometimes there could be a bar
or two in between that, you know, it can
sort of I don't say disregard, but you
know, sometimes it just doesn't happen
back toback. You know, sometimes it
rests for one for a bar or two. That's
the difference between flip A and flip.
flip a is immediately flip bar is, you
know, if it reads it over the next
couple of bars. Um, but anyway, you
could enable if you just want to look at
flip A, you know, keep it true and flip
B and change to false so it wouldn't
read flip B. But, you know, it's I like
them both. I treat them exactly the same
as far as trading.
Intensity one, intensity two, keep them
one and one, 25 and 25. That's for
settings of 1 and 25. and flip B would
be the exact same. Now, under the plots,
now you can change this. Okay,
to differentiate between a flip A and a
flip B is
you can go and change the colors if you
want, but the way I differentiate it is
between the size of the triangle. You
know, it's triangle up, triangle down.
Again, you can change it to whatever you
want in there, but I tend to keep the uh
first one smaller than the second one. I
mean, that's just a personal thing if if
you can always change it to whatever you
like.
Okay. So for more liquid markets um e-
minis 5 years 10 years you go with you
know start at 1 and 25 or sorry 1 and
250 rather. So you know 1 and 250 1 and
250. So 1 1 250 250 1 250 250.
Okay. So adjustments you can make to
these settings.
The intensity. Okay. The intensity the
smaller number is stronger. So, by
having an intensity of one, that's about
as strong as you can get.
I don't I I don't want to use zero as
the strongest.
Actually, I haven't tested it as zero,
but you know, if one is about as strong
as you can get. Sometimes, you know,
with these with Ninja Trader, you put a
val zero and it just doesn't work
properly for some reason. But anyway,
start, you know, one is the strongest
you could get. But as you get higher the
number, the intensity gets weaker. So if
you change the intensity, that's this
one here, intensity one, intensity two
to five, say you change it to five, it's
going to get weaker. And
what that means is you're lowering the
threshold. So instead of, you know, it'd
be like having a
how to say a hole, right?
One would be, you know, the smallest
hole you could have. Five would be a
little bit bigger. So, you know, if
you're draining water through that hole,
you know, if it's a one, it's going to
be letting very little water through. 5
10 15 it's getting bigger. A lot more
water is going to come rushing in.
Delta, which is this next number, delta
1, delta 2,
measures,
you know, the minimum thresholds for
delta that uses to do its calculations.
you know, thinner markets that don't put
in bigger deltas in the bar, use values
that are smaller. I like 25. Um, you
know, it's borderline. Again, I don't
like to split hairs, you know, and say,
you know, it's got to be 25.
You know, if if a market, you could use
50, you could use 35, you know, find a
level that you're comfortable with. I
tend to try and keep you know I tend to
group markets you know whether liquid
thin by liquidity you know thin medium
large and you know the thinner markets I
tend to keep around 25 the thicker
medium markets you know maybe around 100
maybe 75 sometimes I go back and forth
and you know I don't want to like
optimize it to to one thing but you know
I do think there's a sweet spot for many
of these but I try to have you know in
general when I group these markets into
thin and uh thin, medium, and large. You
know, for medium, I I'd probably put in
crude oil. I don't trade a lot of these
other commodities anymore, so I I'm not
up to speed on them. Crude oil, I I jump
between
anywhere between 75 and, you know, and
100. Bonds, I don't use this on bonds,
actually, cuz I got other things I like
with bonds as well. But, um, you know,
bonds, I I would probably use the same
as five years. you know, I would try 200
actually. Again, there's not a big
difference between 200 and say 250, but
there's a big difference between 25 and
and 50, you know, on a thinner market.
On a thicker market, again, you know,
200 to 250 is is not much because you're
trading a lot more volume, but on a
thinner market, it can make a big
difference. Um, you know, so, you know,
experiment, you know, try it and see
what what you're comfortable with. Now,
if you're going to change the setting to
say five and 250,
five would be the intensity, 250 would
be here. You know, you can change it to
five and 500. You know, sometimes I look
at charts with five and 500 to see, you
know, if things, you know, if the
markets are really starting to pick up
or not, you know, and be, you know,
starting to put in more liquidity.
So, you know, I'm going to go through a
bunch of charts.
Again, you know, this is for the month
of basically the month of January, the
first week of February, because, you
know, I want you to see it
in action, right? I want you to see you
the good, the bad, the ugly, basically.
you know, I don't want to sit here and
put up charts, you know, just a
screenshot of a chart and say, "Oh, you
know, yeah, it's he only is putting up
the the pretty charts, you know, where
it's working, you not showing the charts
where where it's not working." So, you
know, I'm going to jump in here with
these different charts. So, give me a
sec. All right. So, this is the first
chart. This is a Euro currency 1 minute
chart. Again, the setting is 1 and 25.
Again, try and keep it during the US
trading hours preferably. I mean, yeah,
Euro currency does put in decent volume
starting around 3:00 a.m. 4:00 a.m., but
you know, if you're in the US, trade US
products during the US hours. If if
you're in Europe, you know, trade the
Europe, you know, trade buns. Buns is a
great contract to trade. Um, DAX is
decent. Euro stocks can be very slow
sometimes, but there's contracts, you
know, in every time zone, you know, the
major contracts in each time zone. You
know in Asia it'd be Nikkei.
So let's take a look here. So starting
on the fourth, what do you got? You got
a buy here a little bit up. Sell failed.
Buy,
you know, going into the close. So you
know you got one decent one. Then the
next day, well, this is the third. So
the next day is the fourth. And you know
what do you got? You got to buy very
early. Okay, you probably might not be
trading there at 6:00 in the morning.
This charts start at 6:00 in the morning
go to 3 p.m. All these charts there some
days where I don't have the data because
for whatever I was did some running
around in the month of January. So um I
wasn't trading so I have my charts open.
So you know then you get this nice buy
here and it's all day up. You get a sell
followed by a quick buy. So the sell
stop you know sell didn't work but you
got the buy come back. This couple buys
there that didn't work.
run into bit of volatility, but you get
the buy signal right before it takes
off, but it did push lower. These, you
know, 2:00 2:00 is when the currencies
close on the pit when there was a pit.
So, in all honesty,
after 2 p.m. liquidity really dries up.
So, be careful if you're trading after 2
p.m.
Okay, so the next day you get a sell
here at the bottom. Again, take things
in context. Are you going lower? Do you
want to take sells? You know, if you're
going higher, I mean, it's up to you.
You know, again, I like to trade trades
in context. But, you know, if you took
this one, you sold it here. Okay, you
got to recognize you're wrong. You know,
don't be getting out way up here. You
get out really quick. So, that one's
wrong. And you get this nice buy signal
here before it makes this nice big run
up.
Some sells, sells, a little buy up
there. This one next day didn't work.
ran into non-farm payrolls and get the
sell signal. Sell and a buy and a buy
that failed some buys. You're just going
sideways. It's Friday afternoon already
Monday. This one didn't work. That one
didn't work. This one, you know, you got
a nice little move up there.
You got a buy then a sell. Buy then some
sells. Some sells.
Some sells, some sells.
Buy failed. Buy failed, sell, buy,
failed, sideways, sideways, down,
sideways, up.
You get this sell signal here.
You know, where do you want to take a
trade? Do you want to take a sell signal
up here or sell signal down there? It's
up to you.
Stays all over um the place. Again, you
know, towards the end of the day, I'm
not necessarily looking to be taking
trades in the I mean after 2 p.m.
rather. I'm not necessarily looking to
take some trades this day. I wish I had
the data. Uh my day is a bit spotty in
here. It's kind of jumpy. You did get
this high signal before my feed got cut
off. 17th on the open again. I wouldn't
be taking that that early in the morning
here. This one
quick sell here. Went down there.
Sideways a sell. Went down. Buy didn't
work out. Then the sell did.
Buy sell real quick. Followed up with a
buy that just went straight up.
sell on the way down, buy, sell again,
buy, didn't work out. Um, you know, 2:00
around the close, you tend to get a bit
of you can get some volume being traded
there. This I don't know, uh, the 19th
again, you're going sideways, back and
forth, back and forth. You get the sell
signal here, went down, went sideways,
and get the big sell signal right before
it fell down. So, you got to ask
yourself, right? Let me see if I can
blow this up here a bit.
I don't want to be like a sounding like
a preacher. Again, it's about taking
small losses. Now, where are you going
to place your stop? You know, you know,
you have your entry bar. You're placing
your stop right behind your entry bar
high or low by a few ticks. Okay? Cuz if
it violates that then, you know, the
reason for the trade is not there. And
would you rather be taking, you know,
five tick losses here, here, here, here
to catch this move here, or I mean, I
don't want to say catch this move, but
you know, you did get a nice move here.
You know, what is that about 70 70 full
ticks? I mean, Euro currency trades in
halves. So, that's a nice move, but this
is a nice move up here. You know, again,
you got to ask yourself, you got this
move up, this move down, then again,
this nice big monster move down. you
know, are you willing to take the small
loss on this trade? On this trade, you
know, on this trade, this one probably a
little scratch. These again is, you
know, right on the open. I probably
wouldn't be looking to take those, but
still, you got to ask yourself, you
know, can you take small losses? You
know, here, yeah, the big sell, then you
got to buy here, right? And goes up, you
know, then you got to sell it comes off.
You know, another buy, it goes up. You
know, it's it's about
cutting your losses short. You know,
this one started to work out, then it
went against you. Get out. You know,
again, this one gave you a sell, but
then it just rallied right against you.
Get out.
This one, I'm not too interested cuz
it's right on the open. You know, this
one failed. This one worked. This one
worked.
And again, that's that's 230. I'm not
really interested
in these ones right on the open. I'm not
interested. Usually before seven, I'm
not really interested in looking at the
market.
This one worked before it turned around.
Give you a buy. Then it fell off
again. It sort of run into that 2 p.m.
time there. Yeah, this one again. You
know, maybe you took this didn't work
out, but then it gave you this buy
really quick.
doesn't really, you know, a little bit
of something maybe there
gets a bit dodgy in here if you expand
it. You sell and buy then sell against
buy then sell. So you catch this move,
sell, but then you screwed on this one.
This one kind of went sideways and you
get this little sell here, but again
it's getting close to the close.
These This one didn't. Again, that's a
little too close to the openings before
seven. I'm not really interested. Seven.
You get this one. You get a little move
here. Here you get a nice little move.
Where's this market at? Okay. Um,
so anyway, uh, you get this little move
up here. You know, here you get a little
bit of a move. So, this one didn't
really work out.
These don't really work out. Then 27th
failure right there. This one worked out
a little bit. This one kind of sideways.
This one didn't work out. This one a
little bit. This one sideways. This one
also sideways.
This one a little bit before going
against you. This is a little bit. Yeah,
it's already after 2:00. Not interested.
This one's a little too early,
but again, you know, you got to decide
when you're going to be trading. There's
a sell. It turned around on you really
quick.
And then you get the buy that goes up
before it curves on you. This is after 2
o'clock already. 2:30 you're pushing.
This is February's non-farm payroll day.
Again, you know, right this is this is
the number here. So, you usually coming
up before the number. It's extremely
quiet. And again, that's a time that I'm
not looking to trade at all.
Later in the day, you get some movement
in here. You know, sell before it sells
off. Another sell right ahead of it
sells off. You got a little buy that
failed on you. There's a little buys
sells in here. You're sort of scratching
in here. Maybe losing a couple ticks.
You got a nice buy there and a nice
sorry nice sell here. Nice sell there.
130. Get this buy that just sort of goes
sideways on you. So that's the one
minute chart. Okay. So this is the uh
Euro currency 8 range chart
and same settings 1 and 25 1 and 25.
Let's see if there's anything.
This is on the fourth and the first day
there was nothing on the third. The
fourth uh what do you got? Okay, so you
got this cell worked its way down. It's
a eight range reversal chart. So each
bar is eight nine ticks. So, even if you
get one bar, that's already nine ticks.
Um, you get this nice buy here. The
first one, yeah, you got a little
something. Maybe the second one
definitely something. This third one, it
popped up against you before one in your
favor. It's kind of sucks. I don't like
that, but you know, sometimes that's
what the market does. Here, it'll pop up
a little bit before it goes against you.
It's tough. You know, I mean, you know,
it's trading is not easy.
This one didn't work.
this one. Yeah, kind of back and forth
on you
here. You sort of ran into some chop.
This was the non-farm payroll number.
That's the uh first Friday. And you can
see you got this little move up here.
This one went down then moved up against
you. Here's a nice move higher. Here's a
nice move lower. But again, this is that
7:30 in here. This is 7:34.
7:35 is right here. 744. I mean, usually
this number I give it about 15 minutes
to settle down,
you know. So, even if you waited, even
if you missed that last one at 7, this
one's around 743.
So, you could have got something here,
something there.
Now, is is is it better to look at a
range chart or a minute chart? Well,
again, it depends on your style of
trading.
Sometimes I think, you know, some of
these indicators work better on range
charts because, you know, when you're
trading a rangebased chart, it's based
on price movement as opposed to time
movement. You know, when you're looking
at a timebased chart, it's
a bar closes when it's time to close. It
doesn't close because you're moving. You
know, the market's moving. There's a
nice little sell there. This at 10:30.
This one didn't really work out
here. What do we got? Some failures
here. Boom, boom, boom. Okay, so you got
three in a row, but you know, you can
have tight stops, right? You just It's
okay. You can get it back on these next
two two or three trades here.
Yeah, you get some of your losses back
here and here. You know, here kind of
goes sideways. Here you get some more.
Here you get some more. Here you get
some more. Here you get a lot.
You know, don't be afraid to take
losses. You know, it's not people don't
like to take losses. I mean, it's okay.
I I understand the psychology behind it,
but you know what? Depending on how
you're trading, you're going to have
losses. You like I said, nothing is
certain.
Here's a nice move up. Here's a nice
move down. Here's a nice little move up
before it goes sideways on you.
Okay, here this day it was just all in
your favor all day long. Here, shows it
goes against you. And here you got a
sell. Couple sells go sideways, couple
buys, go sideways, get stopped out.
Here's sell, but follows back with the
buy. Then here you got the nice sell. It
goes lower.
Nice move up.
A nice sideways here. Sideways. They'll
maybe book a couple losses there.
Here's a nice little winner. This one
loser.
Sideways. sideways.
Nothing. Some say nothing, but you know,
sideways activity.
Um, getting towards the end already.
There's a cell. It kind of goes sideways
on you.
Here's a sell. 720 all day, all morning.
And another cell.
This one doesn't work out. This one
starts to work out then goes sideways.
Somebody had two nice big winners
earlier.
You know, people they want every single
trade to be a winner. Some you're not
going to get every single trade is going
to be a big winner. You know, here you
take a loser, but then you know, you
stick it out and you get this nice nice
big winner here. You know, this is 10730
all the way up to 107. You know, this is
80 here, though. That's 90. Um, you
know, that's a 50 point move.
And then here's the
late in the day you get the little
selloff. All right. So that's the Euro
currency.
Okay. So now uh moving on to the ENQ the
main NASDAQ and what do you got here?
Okay. I'm just going to blow through
this. I don't I don't want to make this
videos too long. So if I start
commentarying on everything, yeah, you
you'll this be a three-hour video. I
just want you to see everything, you
know, each day.
I mean, I said some days are going to be
better than others.
Well, if you could buy it here, you got
a nice move. Sorry. Um, trying to keep
quiet.
Again, you run into, you know, this is 7
pre 7 a.m. You're running into that. You
know, keep that in mind when you're
trading. You know, what time is it? 7.
Really, the NASDAQ isn't going to pick
up until cash open at 8:30 Chicago time.
This is 8:30 here.
Failed
sideways this one. Okay.
again. Yeah, you see it like this, but
this is, you know, 6:00 in the morning,
6:30
in the morning, 6:37.
Yeah. Again, you see it there like these
slow
slowm moving times you tend to get you
tend to get this. I mean you'll be
careful trading precash open in the
equities. That's just general advice.
It's not brain surgery advice. Just you
if you're trading mini NASDAQ you should
be trading it during the most liquid
times. It's a very thinner market.
That's why you see all these mornings in
there.
This was a nice one here. Literally just
get one sim, you know, one trade, excuse
me, one sign like that.
There's market just sort of going
sideways
here. These are failures. I'm not going
to sugarcoat it, but you know, these are
losses. You'll be getting stopped out,
but you get stopped out pretty quick. If
you stick around till 230, you get
chance to cover it back in here.
This is nonfarm payroll here. 7:30.
All right, so that's the uh one minute
chart. Let's take a look at the eight
range real quick.
All right. So,
main eight range chart. Again, I'll try
and just blow through this, but I mean,
you could see how it is here. You get
into some areas with some congestion,
but you get some areas with some nice
moves.
This one failed. Then comes right back
down with a nice a nice trade.
some failures there.
That's a failure, but then it comes
right back with a nice winner.
Now, again, are you willing to risk this
little trade here to catch these trades?
Some people say no. They want every
trade to be like this. They want to sell
here, buy here. But you know, sometimes
you're going to be buying it on the way
down. And you know, then but you want to
get limit your losses and wait for the
times when you're going to get these
moves like this.
Here you take a little loss on this
trade, but then you're patient. You sit
through this next trade. It comes goes
sideways on you and then wham.
failure. Here's a failure. Well, that's
right on the close.
These are towards the close.
Yeah, you break this day down. Yeah, you
have a loss up here. Then you got a nice
sell there. Some sells down here. Some
cells here.
Got a nice little sell here. Follow up
with a nice buy here.
Where are we here?
Okay, what else we got going on here?
This day is just kind of going sideways,
but you know, you are getting a little
bit of something in here and here. So,
even if the market does go sideways, you
know, maybe you could squeeze something
out. So, so that was an NQ. Uh I think
next is I think mini Dow. Let me check.
Uh right. So this is a mini Dow one
minute chart again. Um
you know contract like mini DAO, right?
Thinner traded markets especially if
they're based on equities, mini NASDAQ,
wait till the cash market opens.
This is all precash here basically. Um
you know you can see how it picks up the
volatility. You get a nice sell here.
This one fails. That one fails. This one
a little close to the close. This is
right ahead of the cash. You wait for
the cash to open. No one's holding a gun
to your head. Says you have to trade
pre-market.
But, you know, just sort of run through
these things real quick.
You know, when you see it like this, you
know, someone is dumping their position
thinking the market's going lower for
whatever reason for the near term.
Doesn't always going to be, you know,
you sell here and it just keeps going
lower all day. You know, it's going to
turn at some point. Trail your stop. Um,
you know, people don't understand that
they get short to catch a move like this
and they get out up here thinking, "Oh,
hey, you know, your indicator sucks."
Well, where were you all this time down
here? Why didn't you get out?
I I got I got somebody literally sent me
a chart just like this saying, "Oh, I
didn't know where to get out, so I got
it up here." Well, come on. Um, I should
take a look at your trading and and
reassess it.
Yeah, I see. This is where it gets tough
sometimes, you know, where you have
these sideways moving markets. That was
what, five bucks a tick, I think. Um,
so it's, you know, it's not going to
damage it too much. It's a nice move
there.
These are some failures there.
Again,
you know, you mini DAW is great because
it doesn't give you moves like this. You
know, you can get in, you know, you get
your small little losses in here and
here, wherever, but you get these moves
like that sometimes very quick. You
know, if Trump says something, um, and
you know, if you're positioned on the
right side, it's it's great. But, you
know, have your
have your stops
here. Nice one.
fix these little areas like this, you
know, right ahead of the move.
Excuse me.
This is non-farm payrolls here.
So, anyway, so that's the one minute
chart. Uh I'll pull up the eight range
chart. Okay, so this is the mini Dow YM
8 range chart again. Um I'll just go
through these days. Some days there
wasn't very much on this eight range
chart. Still nevertheless show you, you
know, when it worked, when it didn't
work. So you get an idea of you know
what sort of charts or time frames you
can be trading. Of course again you
don't have to stick to eight range
chart. You could use 10 range, you use
five range, use 100 tick chart, 987 tick
chart. It's up to you. It's up to you.
you know, it's it's don't have to copy
exactly what I do. You know, I mean,
everybody
has a different way of trading, right?
Um, you know, pick up Market Wizards.
Everyone's successful in the book Market
Wizards, but you know what? There's 20
guys in there. They each trade
differently. No one's exact copy of
anybody else. You part of trading is
developing your own style.
You know, people come to me ask me,
"Hey, can you teach me to trade?" Yeah,
I can teach you to trade, but you know,
eventually you're going to develop your
own style. You're not going to be a
carbon copy of me,
you know. So, eight range mini Dow, it's
average at best, maybe break even, maybe
a small loss over that month. But, you
know, I want you to see it. I don't want
you to say, "Oh, he's only showing the
charts where they're working um better."
But again, you know, these were markets
in what I consider thin traded markets
and
they have the same settings 1 and 25. 1
and 25.
You know, I'm not using the default
settings. I gave you my settings there,
right? These are my settings. Okay?
And it's not like I'm r I'm curve
fitting it. You know, these are the
markets. These are the ranges. It's all
the same. 1 and 25, 1 and 25, 1 and 25.
Thin markets on, you know, one minute
charts. So now I'm going to get into the
E- minis in the 5 years. You know,
settings of 1 and 25 cuz these are
thicker markets. So the,
you know, the delta setting is going to
be higher. If I use 25, it'll probably
kick off a lot more. So let's take a
look.
Okay, so this is the E- mini one minute
chart. Now, you know, right off the bat,
I can see there's a lot of signals.
So I don't know if I want to stick with
one and 25 or one and 250 rather. You
know, maybe in my trade I might want to
bust it out to one and 350,
you know, 500. It depends. You could
play around with it a little bit more. 1
and 25. It's going to be a lot of
signals. So, I know it's uh letting a
lot of trades in. You I could filter it
out. You know, by using a higher delta
number of above 250, you'll be filtering
out some of the the weaker signals, but
still, you're getting some decent
signals. You know, this day is a tough
day here. Here you're getting some nice
trades. Here's some nice trades. Here's
some nice trades.
Again, you know, not every day is going
to be
any be picture perfectly.
on days like this. I mean, it looks like
we're in a tight range. Actually, you
know, there there's a couple points
movements here and here and here.
You know, this is where the real power
comes in. If you're on a trend day, it
just keeps you on the right side of the
market all day long. Like this day is
just straight, I'll say straight up, but
you know, it's moving at a nice 45°ree
angle and it's basically keeping you in.
It's giving you kicking off all these
little buy signals here after, you know,
after the cash open.
You're talking to move from, you know,
62 up to uh, you know, almost 80. I
mean, but every day is not like this.
Yeah, you know, those are the days you
love as a trader, but unfortunately
a lot of days are just like crappy like
this
or this even.
What you like is those trend days,
but unfortunately you don't always get
it and you just get these small trades
like this, you know, up up.
But again, a lot of trading is being
able to understand when you're wrong.
And you know, that's what this this
indicator can really help you. Let's see
if I can blow this up a bit more here.
So, you know, I know I have this bar
here, right? This is the signal bar. If
we're getting, you know, a tick or two
below there, three ticks below, I know
I'm wrong. So, I know that this is going
to stop if I get stopped out down here.
Okay? Okay. So, you know, this is the
signal bar here, right? Low low at uh 91
and 3/4. If I'm getting down to 91 and a
quarter, I'm wrong. Okay. That's only
two ticks, right? A two tick um you
know, stop. You're getting in in the
next bar somewhere anywhere between 92
and a quarter and 92.
And you know, your stop is down here at
91 and a quarter. So, three ticks.
Okay. You know, are you willing to take
three ticks of of heat, you know, and
and hope for something? You know, here's
minus three ticks. minus three ticks.
Well, this is non-farm payroll day. But,
um, you know, having, you know, have
have some tight stops, you know, here,
this one's, you know, you lose you risk
three ticks a couple times, but then
you're getting, you know, a move from
I don't know what this is, 90 72 and a
half
and up to 5 and a half.
So, anyway, that's the one minute chart.
Let's take a look now at the uh what
else do I got here is the five range. I
think it's a five range. Not much on the
five range actually, but still uh I'll
put it up there for you guys to see. I
don't know why I thought I had a three
range. I I prefer a three range now on
the E- Minis more than the the five
range. Not that much here. You could see
now here's something you could have got
there. put them up there. You know,
here's some nice buys. It's not like
there's a lot, but the ones that you're
getting are pretty decent here. You got
a couple points. I mean, you know, I I
hate to say it, but you know, I know
people that Yeah, they're they're
patient and not everybody is patient
sometimes. You know, it's hard for me to
sit through um
you know, days where nothing's
happening. Um, I've had to trade markets
like that where you're just sitting
there watching paint dry, nothing's
happening like, and you know, you're
looking for trades, but there's nothing
doing. So, a five range with this
setting, you're not getting a lot, but
the ones that you get are pretty decent.
Decent in the sense of a few points, you
know, I mean, there's people that build
their whole trading strategy just around
getting two points a day out of out of
the market.
And, you know, the last one I'll look at
is this five-year
This is a uh one minute chart. Yeah,
five years is a nice chart to trade. Uh
nice chart, nice market to trade because
you know when it trends it it moves can
move quite nicely.
Come on.
Okay. Well, really this one you should
really blow up. But you know, this is
one you should test yourself. But you
know again you're getting some nice
moves you know couple point couple ticks
couple ticks couple ticks three four
five ticks you know a couple points even
but you know this is a market where you
can it's very liquid so it's very easy
to get out you know there's very good
size in the market
I should open it up a bit more so it's a
little bit easier to see
you know so here this one failed you get
something out of this you get something
out of that you get something out of
that
you get something out of this. Well,
this is the close. Um,
this one, you know, just kind of goes
sideways on you. This one, you get
something out of that.
You got these buys that fail, then you
get this nice sell that nice works out
beautifully.
This one fails on you. There's no way to
put it other than it this one just
it just spanked you. Um, but you got to
have a stop in. You know, you know that
if you're getting stopped out, if it's
trading up where this carrot is, you
know, where the triangle is, that's just
that's where your stop is. You know, the
triangle prints at a certain uh
distance.
And I know that if we get to that
distance, that's where I should be
getting out. Yeah. But then, okay, you
get stopped out here, you get stopped
out here. Look at this.
This is a one minute chart. And over the
next two minutes, it jumps from 30 up to
03. you know, in the five years that's
like 15 ticks right there.
Again, another example just like that.
Yeah, this one is in your favor all day.
Again, here is a nice move. Here's a
nice move. You know, 250, you know, you
could go to some brokers and you can get
250 bucks margin. So, even if you're
just trading two or three lots, you
know, it's it's very cost effective. You
can do it. You can do it. I mean, you
know, people say, "I don't have money to
trade."
I don't know what to expect to come into
the market. You don't need 20,000. I
mean, it's nice to have $20,000 in your
account. You know, but some people want
to get started trading in their paper
trading. And I say get a small account.
You know, you could trade contracts like
the 5 years with, you know, a few
hundred. I mean, you should at least
have a couple thousand in your account
minimum. But if you know, and don't
think the margin's 250, you're going to
trade 10 contracts if you got 2 and a
half thousand. No, it's 250. trade, you
know, two contracts maybe. You know, you
want to be around in case you suffer
some uh trading losses. You know, that's
one of the problems is people get over
margined or not, you know, they're
highly leveraged rather, not over
margined.
You know, but then, you know, you catch,
you know, a couple trades like this, you
know, you could slowly build up your
account. Everybody wants to come in and
take whatever their account is, divide
it by the margin, and that's how many
contracts they're going to trade. Oh,
don't do that. But yet, some people
insist on doing it. You know, they think
trading is the easiest way. So, the more
money they can put into it, the faster
they can trade, the more money they'll
make it. It doesn't work that way. Okay?
So, like this example, perfect example
of
it just turns on you really quick over
the next bar. Okay? So, then it comes
up, you get something here. This one
kind of works, you know, then it starts
going against you. This one goes against
you sideways, but then again later, you
get this nice trade. You know, again,
are you willing to take a couple small
losses to catch this to catch this trade
here? Catch this trade here. Again,
people see this and think, "Oh, this is
terrible. This is terrible." It's about
managing your risk. That's what trading
is about is managing risk.
I mean, for certain people, it's just
all about risk management. They don't
care what the market's doing. You know,
they got a position on, they're good at
managing their risk, they'll they'll
become profitable.
you know, they don't necessarily go in
with a view, you know, they just for
them, it's all about managing the risk.
Managing the risk.
I mean, I don't know how to describe
their method of trading. But for them,
it's just about, you know, hey, you
know, I got a position on if I manage it
properly.
Sometimes I'll be right, sometimes I'll
be wrong. It's all about managing the
risk. So, again, you know, this one you
got a buy here, then came back with a
sell that didn't work out. Okay, you're
stopped out. You know, you took your
first trade, you take a maybe a scratch
or a tick loss. Second trade, you get
stopped out. Well, then look, you're
patient. Okay, you get another nice
little buy here. Okay, maybe thinking ah
I give up on this trade. Then here
you get the signal again
and how it just jumps jumps up on you.
That's what I'm talking about with
sweeping the market. You know, sometimes
it's going to be like this in quiet
markets. Somebody's moving some size,
moving some size, but and what causes
the market to move is absence of buyers
or sellers. And what that means is if
you have a big buyer come in and sweep
the market, lift up all the sellers,
there's no more sellers. And that's how
you get this market to move like that.
Okay. So this is
what day is this? This is the first
Okay. So, this is uh already the end of
the month or this beginning of uh
February already. So, you can see, you
know, I you know, I I put up a lot of
different charts, a lot of different
settings.
Not a lot of different I mean a few
settings rather, but on a lot of
different charts. So you can see I'm not
trying to like pick the most optimal. I
mean some people will. I know some
people have tested this
over many different markets, a lot of
different setting numbers and are
trading the best ones. You know, I'm not
necessarily I don't say that you can't
do that. I mean, there's nothing wrong
with that. Um, you know, cuz you want to
find what what you think works best for
the market. I mean, if you don't have
faith in what you're doing, then you'll
fail. Regardless of whatever it is
you're doing, whether it's trading,
whether it's making scrapbooks or um you
know, making wire jewelry, if you don't
have faith in your abilities and what
you're doing, you you won't succeed. And
you know, so what I'm showing you, I'm
showing you these different settings,
the same settings over different
markets, different types of charts,
and how they are. You know, again, I I
go back and
first thing I say, I should make this
the first slide. Don't use the default
settings thinking that's all that's
needed. No, you know, these are
preferred settings that I I like to look
at nowadays. And you know, markets are
always evolving. And again, you know,
who knows in six 6 months from now,
maybe instead of 1 and 25, it'll be five
and 30 or something. Um, you know,
again, these are not lines drawn in the
sand that you have to you have to use,
and if you don't use them, you'll fail.
No, not at all. But um you know, these
are the numbers that I'm comfortable
with and and I do adjust them. You know,
I said I don't have bonds on here.
Bonds, I think I use 200, okay? Because
the volume is slightly lesser than the 5
years and and the E- Mini. So, I'm not
going to use 250 on a market that's got
slightly lesser volume, right? It's
going to be it's going to be a smaller
delta number. So, instead of one and
250, I I'll use one and 200.
And if I'm fine with it, you know, I'll
run it over a week or so, you know, back
test it over a week, see how it looks,
and if I'm fine with it, then that's
what I'm going to use.
So again, thanks for watching this
video. And uh, you know, any questions,
shoot me an email.
You know, this these indicators I'm I'm
now giving away with I say giving away
with the software, but you know, the
only way you can get them now is buying
the software of, you know, the main
order flows trader. you you see me use
them on bar charts because it's easier
to show you on on a footprint chart.
I'll get carried away with explanations
of things, but I don't know. I mean,
some people say, "Oh, you should just
sell these indicators separately."
We'll see. Um, we'll see. You know, I
don't like people getting them and not
reading. You know, people don't
necessarily want to take the time to
read the instructions. I'll say, "Don't
use the settings." And they'll use the
settings and they'll say, "It doesn't
work." And that's what settings are you
using. That's why I created this video,
you know, it's to help people
get comfortable with this and understand
what why these settings exist, you know,
what they mean and, you know, how you
can change them. It's not like here it
is. Turn your loose and that's it. You
know, I want you to succeed. You
honestly, if I didn't care, if I didn't
give a it just give me your money
and that's the end of it.
You know, if it doesn't work, doesn't
work. Good luck on you. No, you know, I
feel bad if someone says, you know, I I
it's not working. You know, can I have
my money back? Well, you know, I'll sit
down with you, try to understand why
it's not working for you and you know
how you're trading. You know, honestly,
some guy came to me, bought it. First
guy that bought it, he trades 15-minute
charts. He says, you know, it's not
working for me. Okay, well, how do you
use it? I use it on a on a 15-minute
chart. Well, I know it's not going to be
effective on a 15-minute chart. I would
like to say yes, but I I know. I mean,
order flow over the longer the duration
tends to lose its effectiveness. Now,
that's not to say you can't use
orderflow on a 15-minute chart, a
30-minut chart, but you're going to get
very very few
trading signals. I mean, you will get
some, but
the the frequency of them is going to be
very um
infrequent. So again, it's it's not that
you can't use it on on long-term charts,
but you know, realize that it's it's not
going to happen. It's not you're not
going to get the same results as you
would on a shorter time frame chart. So,
you know, if if if you're using the
indicators and you're struggling, let me
know what you're trading, what time
frames you're looking at, and you know,
we we'll go from there. Again, you know,
I'm here to help. I'm not here to just
screw you over and and and take your
money and you never hear from me again.
although sometimes that I think that's
what some people think. But um you know
I want people to succeed and if I didn't
care I wouldn't keep making these videos
for you guys. So anyway I'm sort of
going off on my soap box but um you know
again thanks for watching this and you
know I hope now you have a better
understanding of how to use this
indicator, what it's for, what it does
and how you can use it in your trading.
So thank you and see you on the inside.